hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute 29 jährigen bisschen
ungewohnte location mann der gerade das
video aufnehmen aber ich habe mir
gedacht das würde eigentlich ganz gut
passen weiß heute was reden ich habe
mich vor ein paar tagen auf youtube
video empfohlen bekommen was heißt
anders arschloch aus der bahn also beim
videoportal youtube in fräulein chaos
und die berichte gelegen video darüber
dass sie quasi in der wanne unangenehme
begegnung mit einem anderen bahnfahrer
hatte und ja ich bin durch meinen
kleinen ausschnitt von allen danken die
mich in mein sichtfeld gewinnt mit band
auf sich aufmerksam zu machen oder sie
das video gesehen habe dachte ich mir
hey ich hatte jetzt vor einer woche auf
eine etwas komische situationen zwar
nicht in der bahn aber das waren im klub
und ich habe mir auch gedacht okay ich
würde eigentlich ganz gern mal drüber
reden vorher möglich allerdings sagen
dass nicht über keinen ihnen die mitleid
suche und ich möchte auch nicht
kommentare jetzt verlangen von wegen ehe
macht doch nichts draußen doch alles nur
spaß
nein ich wollte einfach nur diese
geschichte mal erzählen weil ich mich
danach gefühlt habe ich fange mal von
vorne an und bahrain zwei wochen mit ihr
studienkollegen von mir feiern wir waren
unterwegs weil wir an dem tag die
wetterlage abgegeben hatten
auf jeden fall waren wir eher in einem
restaurant was essen und sind danach
auch die ringe gegangen weil jeder der
köln preis auf den ringen kann man
abends gut feiern gehen also die
ringerin phase eine straße die so um den
kern von köln rrh umgeht und was
investierbaren der sekte kürze wird noch
halten die klapsmühle gegangen ja
deshalb ein stinknormaler club war ich
hätte das ding dort ist kein kratzer
club darin keine karten
aber es ist zumindest ganz lokal laden
und das hatten wir so als starter für
den abend genutzt als wir dort waren wir
sehr viele 16-jährige darin waren habe
ich direkt irgendwie schon 234 bilder
gemacht mit irgendwelchen anderen
gruppen und danach haben wir uns bereits
und häppchen geholt mit köln wenn man
halt
rand gestellt und wollten nun wissen wir
bringen auf jeden fall standen dort am
rand haben uns mit ihm unterhalten
keiner von ihnen die handlungsweise
betrunken und dann erhalten mädel an und
die begleiten sie als diva indirekt den
sitzen oder so die ware mit ein paar
freundinnen und unter anderem halt auch
mit ihrem freund das meldet haben auf
jedenfalls du mir an und meinte so hey
bist du nicht laserdrucker von instagram
und ich meine ja das bin ich in dieser
hecke fläche machen nicht sehr klar und
nehmen sie das handy machen bild mit ihr
und danach halt wieder zurück zur eine
ganze normale situationen die sache
jetzt halt auch immer für mich leute
fragen die auf der straße oder im club
oder keine ahnung wo eltern nicht
eigentlich immer ja es gab derweil
situationen wo ich nicht ja gesagt habe
und das war einmal
weil in ihrem treppenhaus war und von
dort aber ein anderes mal wo ich gerade
im streit mit einem familienmitglied hat
sich zwischendurch foto machen aber
sonst wirklich in jeder situation immer
ja und machtlosen und genauso halt auch
mit diesen medien anhalt im klub und wie
viel freizeit auch dabei wir haben das
bild gemacht die zurückgegangenen leuten
war danach auf jeden fall kurz darauf
mit einem kumpel weil er den laden hat
eckige luftbad sind wir halt danach
wieder reingegangen sondern freunden und
wollten uns halt dann irgendwie ja da
noch ein bisschen kölsche nehmen und
sollten danach reagiert auch einmal
fliegt mir ein bierglas an den kopf
einfach ein volles kölsch lauf voll an
den schädel wehgetan alles voller bier
gewesen bei mir und ich habe mir in der
situation halt erstmal gucken mich um
ich komme wieder rein ich habe kein hier
was gesagt dann habe ich halt nur
gesehen wie die freunde von diesen mädel
mit dem ich halt das foto gemacht habe
mich angeguckt hat und irgendwie so
schnell weg gegangen ist und ich wollte
die man hinterher geht um fragen die
charakter ich habe mich nicht an eine
freundin herangemacht ich habe lediglich
ein foto mit ihr gemacht wird wollte
wollte allerdings draußen gehört haben
ein kollege von mir an der stelle an der
er hat direkt mit gewehrt gegen die
türsteher die haben überhaupt nicht
gemacht erst youtuber erhole ich mich
von einem dach geworfen weil er viele
anderen typen verstanden die behandlung
aber ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich für die
lassen sich eine sondersituation
natürlich sagen und ich habe doch gar
nicht bemerkt habe aber gedacht ersten
scheibe laden hat mich hingestellt die
zahlen draußen waren sie mir ein anderer
club gegangen alles gut haben war dass
man scheißegal wusst ich habe nichts
falsch gemacht dass einfach nur dulde
leute dort gewesen aber da habe ich das
revue passieren lassen macht mir gedacht
war das für eine dumme aktion ähnlich
machen fusion mit dem medienriesen foto
machen möchte ich ihn nach draußen
getrübte freude sei jetzt mir
entscheiden kölschglas an den kopf und
ein türsteher sie darüber völlig
zusammenhangslos ohne irgendwelche
gründe und hintergründe zu erfragen
fährt dem mich und meine kollegen nach
draußen aktion in dem video von fräulein
haus ging darum dass ihnen der bahn
stand und dort hat sie ein typ an
gemacht und sexuell belästigt bei mir
wartet einfach auch eine komische
situation dass ich quasi im club
missverständnisse aufgetreten dadurch
dass ich mit meiner freundin getötet
habe einfach nur kurzen foto gemacht
habe ich konnte mit ihr unterhalten habe
und dann ist weder nachhaltig hollstadt
meinen kopf geflogen nicht
rausgeschmissen
das war die story vom arschloch im club
das war sind ihr vom video meine damen
und herren ich habe mir wirklich einfach
gedacht ich muss doch irgendwie
mitteilen weil die schweden mit meinem
kopf immer wenn ich jetzt einen club
gehe denke ich - alter nicht dass wir
gegen katar 4 tragt eure meinungen der
ganzen story in die kommentare
für mich auf jeden fall mega
interessieren ich weiß nur dass
wahrscheinlich andere leute in eine
situation dass er anders reagiert hätten
und sehr viel aggressiver auf die
datenerfassung zugestimmt werden aber
mein gott ich meine wollten hier im klub
gehen und so habe ich mir da nicht lange
im ausgang gespart die türsteher
aktionen wie gesagt nicht einfach nur
heute danach gefühlt euch mal dieses
tolle mitzuteilen weil einfach ein
komisches erlebnis bei uns auch schon
lange nicht mehr diese story time wählte
videos gemacht und ja vielleicht hat
sich ja gefallen
vielleicht weil ich die kommentare und
jetzt ratet hier
ist ihr vom video ihr könnt jetzt hier
meinen kanal abonnieren oder ionen
meinen strecken ihr findet jetzt bei
andere videos und ben ihren abonnenten
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
wird vom die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]